hello my name is lilia Beaudoin I am a
director of a pharmacol genetics and
genetic testing laboratory at the Mayo
Clinic in Rochester Minnesota and I'm
very glad that you could come today for
my presentation entitled clinical
applications in pharmacogenetics I just
wanted to let everybody know that they
can feel free to ask questions
throughout my presentation any time
during the presentation and I will
answer the questions at the end of my
presentation so without further ado I'll
get started okay so just a brief
introduction to pharmacogenetics
pharmacogenetics is a component of
individualized medicine and it focuses
on how genetic factors influence
individual responses to different
medications and it can include things
like drug efficacy and side effects and
adverse events to drugs so the cooler
goals of pharmacogenetics are to
minimize adverse drug events or a des
and to maximize drug efficacy
pharmacogenetics has been touted as the
right drug at the right dose in the
right patient a major component of many
pharmacogenetic tests is looking at
enzymes that metabolize our metabolize
the drug or activate the drug and so
basically what can happen with these
enzymes is that they may have a
polymorphism or a variant and anywhere
within the gene in the coding region or
introns are in image outside of the gene
and different elements that that control
the gene function and so based on the
polymorphism it may have a specific
effect on the enzyme activity and so an
individual could
become a poor metabolizer have poor
activity of this enzyme or an individual
may have intermediate or extensive or
ultra rapid enzyme activity and these
are the basic categories for
pharmacogenetics so the basic phenotypic
categories so something was an extensive
has extensive enzyme activity is
considered to be wild type or basically
have normal activity an individual who
has one heterozygous variant that
negatively affects enzyme activity would
be considered to be have intermediate
enzyme activity an individual with two
inactivating variants would have poor
enzyme activity and then on the other
side some individuals may have multiple
copies of a gene for example in the case
of sip to d6 or they may have a
activating promoter variant for example
in the case of SIP to see 19 and this
can lead to ultra rapid enzyme activity
so in this chart here you can see in the
top part of the graph somebody who is an
extensive metabolizer as they're given a
dose of a drip of the drug shown with
the arrows they rapidly metabolize the
drug down to normal or little plasma
levels of the drug in the bottom panel
somebody who has a poor metabolizer each
time they're given the drug they're not
metabolizing it efficiently so the
plasma level levels of the drug build up
over time and what this can lead to is
an adverse drug event especially if the
drug is given in its active form so
basically toxic levels of the drug build
up alternatively if the drug is given as
a prodrug where it's not active but
needs to be activated by the specific
enzyme they will receive very little
benefit from the drug so they'll have
ineffective therapy and
in any case what this can quetta me too
is non-compliance in the patient and it
can lead to a lot of different trial and
error with drug dosing changes different
drugs and eventually or what's been
found with the literature's that the
patient might just decide they don't
want to take any drugs to treat their
condition and this is of course a
unfavorable situation so that's why
pharmacogenetics is so important in many
cases because it helps in providing the
right drug for the right patient in the
beginning as far as drug labels there
are many different drugs that have
labeling information related to
pharmacogenetics and these labels can
include information related to drug
exposure and clinical response
variability risk for adverse events
there are some cases where there's
actually genotype specific dosing
information in the drug label
information about mechanisms of drug
action and information about different
genes involved in metabolizing and the
target and disposition of the drug and
there are several examples of
fda-approved drugs with pharmacogenetics
related label information as I've shown
here in this slide this is actually just
a very short list and if you go to the
website that's listed at the bottom of
the side you can see a more extensive
list but I showed this this because
these are some of the examples that I'm
going to be talking about today so
there's this slide and then the next
slide shows some additional pharmacol
some additional fda-approved drugs with
pharmacogenetics related label
information that I'm going to be talking
about today and I won't talk about all
of these but I will highlight on most of
them the first example that I want to
discuss today has to do with clopidogrel
and in March of 2010 the FDA actually
Institute
a our labor update to clip integral to
indicate the importance for
pharmacogenetic testing of the SIP to
see night team G so clip integral also
known as plavix is a very commonly used
antiplatelet agent it's given as a
prodrug so it requires activation and
one of the major enzymes that activates
clopidogrel is cytochrome p450 to see 19
also known as sip to see 19 clopidogrel
is given to reduce atherosclerosis
including myocardial infarction stroke
and vascular death in patients with
acute coronary syndrome and or following
percutaneous coronary intervention of
PCI which can include things like
stenting clippety girl is often given as
an alternative to aspirin or in
combination with aspirin which is known
as dual antiplatelet therapy and there's
really a highly variable response to
clopidogrel which is due to many
different things including underdosing
of the drug interaction with other drugs
and also genetic factors so as I
mentioned sip to see 19 metabolizes
clopidogrel to its active form and
there's two common loss of functional
meals in the sub 2 cm 80 mg and these
are known as star 2 and star three and
you can see here that I've listed the
the frequencies of these alleles in
different ethnic groups and start to a
star three are associated with lower
levels of the active metabolite of
clopidogrel and also associated with a
market decrease in platelet
responsiveness to [ __ ] integral which is
also known as higher on treat platelet
aggregation so basically individuals
with these loss of functional meals have
a very much lower response to clip it on
it may not be effective in them
so consequently these alleles are
associated with an increased rate of
subsequent cardiovascular events and
even death and this was shown in a major
paper published by the New England
Journal of Medicine in 2009 where there
was a relative fifty-three percent
increased risk of death from
cardiovascular causes MI or stroke and a
three-fold increase risk of stent
thrombosis in individuals who were
heterozygous or homozygous for the star
two allele there's also a interesting
star allele and sub to see 19 that plays
a different role in response to click
little girl and this is the star 17 a
meal which is located in the promoter of
sub 2 scene 18 and is associated with
increased expression of say to see 19 so
individuals who have the star 17 will
have an enhanced response to click
little girl because they're they're
converting it to its active form much
more rapidly than individuals without
star 17 they also have reduced clinical
event rates however I'm the negative
side they have an increased risk of
bleeding and homeless i gossiped ii for
this star 17 allele has a proximately
fourfold increased occurrence of
bleeding so sick to see 19
pharmacogenetic testing for cliff
integral is currently available however
routine clinical use of seducing a team
genotyping is not recommended for the
2011 guidelines by the American College
of Cardiology American and the American
Heart Association guideline paper and
this is because they did not find
sufficient clinical outcome evidence to
support this type of testing however
certain clinical groups still feel that
it is important to test specific
subgroups of patients that are really
high risk for example those who are
undergoing pci or coronary stent
in addition to it address the concerns
put forward by the ACC there are some
large randomized prospective outcome
trials that are currently underway that
should help address some of these
clinical questions ok the next topic I
want to talk about is it has to do with
the drug called warfarin and in 2007 in
August the FDA updated the warfarin drug
label to include information about the
69 gene and warfarin sensitivity and
then they further added in January 2010
they further updated the label to
include the effect of the vcore see one
gene and they also added pharmacogenetic
guided dosing ranges to the label which
I'll show in a couple slides so unlike
lipitor or warfarin is a very commonly
prescribed drug it's an anticoagulant
and it's used for the short and long
term management of thromboembolic
disorders your friend is very
challenging to dose so often individuals
undergoing trial and error period in
order to get the dose to the right level
so that their prothrombin time or INR is
in the therapeutic range and it's a very
narrow therapeutic range and individuals
who are warfarin sensitive can have an
elevated INR where they have a risk for
major bleeding complications and this is
most likely to occur within the first
few weeks of initiating treatment
conversely individuals who are more
warfarin existent will have a sub
therapeutic inr and have thrombotic
complications and there's a wide range
in warfarin dose requirements so this
study looked at about 2300 individuals
and they showed that approximately a
third of the patients required five to
six milligrams of warfarin per day and
five milligrams per day is jenna is the
general starting dose for war from that
most people receive unless they have
some other indication clinical
indications that would require a
different dose but most patients start
on about five milligrams per day however
you can see here only about a third of
the patients actually stay on five
milligrams per day another approximately
third go lower than that and another
approximately third go higher than that
and here on the right side of the graph
with the higher doses that's associated
with warfarin resistance so they require
higher doses of warfarin to achieve
therapeutic inr and then these
individuals on the left side are
considered to be more warfarin sensitive
and we're from pharmacogenetics that is
interesting in the fact that it looks at
both pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic
aspects so this figure here shows on the
left side the pharmacokinetic piece of
warfarin pharmacogenetics now
pharmacokinetics essentially means what
the body does to the drug so here we're
talking about the metabolism of warfarin
or breaking down a boyfriend and work
friend is given as an isomeric mixture
of r and s warfarin s warfarin is by far
the more active form and s warfarin is
your majority of it is metabolized by
sub 2c9 and so this is where the sub 2 c
9 gene comes into play on the right side
you see the pharmacodynamic piece of
warfarin and pharmacodynamics is is
essentially what the drug does to the
body so what Warford does is that it
inhibits an enzyme known as vitamin k
epoxide reductase or décor and B Corps
is encoded for by the vcore seen one
gene and by inhibiting V Corps this
prevents the vitamin K cycle and keeps
the vitamin k-dependent clotting factors
in the inactive state
so forward fun pharmacogenetic testing
we essentially look at two genes 69 and
décor c1 and we also the FDA recommends
looking at the star two and the star
three alleles for sub to see nine and
then a promoter variant in beaker C one
known as minus 1639 g2a and you can see
on this table now this comes directly
from the warfarin or coumadin packet
insert this is the genotype based dosing
guidelines put forward by the FDA so the
left column is the new Corsi one
genotype for that promoter variant and
the cup the a row across the top is the
69 genotype for the star tuna star three
alleles and you can see that depending
on the combination of alleles there's a
recommended dose requirement and you
have just listed the allele frequencies
in some different ethnic groups for a
star to do and star three alleles as
well as the vcore see one variant and it
is interesting to point out here that
you can see in asians the vcore see an
unburied occurs in eighty-nine percent
of asians and it's thought to be
responsible for the majority of warfarin
sensitivity in that ethnic group so the
in 2010 the journal of american college
of cardiology published the mail or the
medco may award for an effectiveness
study and what this was was an
evaluation of hospitalization rates in
patients who were beginning warfarin
therapy and genotyping versus historical
controls without genotyping and they
followed up this patient group for six
months after warfarin dosing in the
genotype group they found that patients
who had sorry in the genotype group this
group of patients who had moderate or
high sensitivity warframe were given a
lower dose of the drug and had more
frequent monitoring whereas patients
with a lower sensitivity to warfarin
given a higher dose of the drug and what
they found was that work patients whose
warfarin dosing was guided by genotype
had thirty one percent fewer
hospitalizations for any reason and
hospital admissions for thromboembolism
are bleeding which contributed to a
third of all hospitalizations or
twenty-eight percent less frequent in
the genotype group so what this study
suggested was that the outcomes were
better in patients who had genotyping
prior to warfarin prescription now this
is still a controversial topic and
several groups have given out guidelines
and recommendations for warfarin testing
and essentially there's some groups that
support it in some groups that don't
support it the American College of
medical genetics the College of American
Pathologists and the national academy of
clinical biochemistry do recommend
warfarin dosing sorry warfarin
pharmacogenetic testing and in some
cases for example the American College
of medical genetics they recommend it
specifically in orthopedic patients
however on the other side the American
College of chest physicians the american
society of hematology and the Centers
for Medicare and Medicare services do
not recommend warfarin testing or from
pharmacogenetic testing they believe
that similar to the political story that
more randomized perspectives prospective
clinical trials with outcomes are
necessary to support this type of
testing and in fact CMS the Center for
Medicare and Medicaid Services announced
that Medicare would not reimburse for
one friend pharmacogenetic testing
except in the setting of randomized
control trials okay moving on to the
next June drug pair and this is this
drug as amount of tea can
and there was the FDA updated the
immunity can label in july two thousand
and five for the indication of arena tkm
toxicity due to a deficiency in the
ugt1a1 gene so ugt1a1 it's a primary
enzyme involved in the in a conjugation
reaction known as glucuronidation of the
drug arre no t can animate OT can is a
chemotherapeutic agent used for the
treatment of solid tumors however
individuals who take arena t can can
occasionally have very severe or and
sometimes fatal leukopenia neutropenia
or diarrhea which is directly linked to
polymorphisms in the ugt1a1 gene so this
FDA label update was to recommend
reduced unity candle seen in patients
who have specific ugt1a1 genotypes so
here's just a little figure that shows
how arena to you can is metabolized and
it is given as a prodrug and it's
metabolized by carboxylesterase 'as to
its active form known as sn-38 and sn-38
works by blocking DNA replication in
order for the body to get rid of sn-38
it requires conjugation reaction by
ugt1a1 to become a sn-38 blue quran ID
and as I mentioned there are specific
ugt1a1 variants that the FDA has
recognized as being associated with
these severe side effects to renew t can
and these specific variants are
occurring the promoter so in the
promoter ta n repeat region are
sometimes known as the tata box there's
a variability in the number of ta
repeats emerging from five to eight
repeats the wild-type repeat is 60
there's 60 a repeats in the wild wild
type situation
ta5 is very close to wild-type however
ta7 and ta 8 I should let me back up ti
5 is close to what I type in fact that
there is still very good activity of the
enzyme however ta7 and ta8 have highly
decreased activity and in patients who
have ta 7 and ta 87 and 88 pedes they're
at a much higher risk for these severe
in OT can side effects um there's also
other polymorphisms and mutations that
can occur throughout the ugt1a1 gene and
those can be tested for as well and
interestingly as a side note variance in
ugt1a1 are associated with hereditary
disorders of bilirubin including gilbere
syndrome and craig learn ajar types 1
and 2 so next I'm going to talk about
hypersensitivity to certain drugs do to
hla human leukocyte antigen variability
so specifically I'm going to talk about
carbamazepine and a back of year which
have FDA approved pharmacogenetic
related drug label updates due to
variability in hlad gene so first a
brief background about human leukocyte
antigen and drug hypersensitivity drug
hypersensitivity is a very broad term
and it affects seven about seven percent
of the general population and
individuals who have drug hypersensitive
sensitivity can have a variety of
reactions many of them not specific
including disorders some of them very
severe of the skin and mucosal surfaces
on hepatitis GI bleeding you might
pneumonitis bone marrow suppression line
and death and really almost on drugs can
induce a hypersensitivity reactions
reaction and they're typically dose
independent and unpredictable HLA plays
a central role in the immune reaction it
initiates the immune response by
presenting antigen to t-cell receptor
and the HLA genes are located the major
histocompatibility complex region of
chromosome 6 there are more than 10
highly polymorphic HLA genes including a
chilling be and hla-b is the major June
at the funk currently at the focus of
association with drug hypersensitivity
so the first application i'm going to
talk about in terms of drug
hypersensitivity is hla-b 1502 and
carbamazepine carbamazepine is an
anticonvulsant it's used to treat
epilepsy certain psychiatric disorders
and neuropathic pain and
hypersensitivity to carbonate speed is a
leading cause of a very severe disorder
known as stevens-johnson syndrome and
toxic epidermal necrolysis or sjm sjs te
n this is a an immune complex mediated
hypersensitivity disorder and as I
mentioned is very serious serious
disorder of the skin and mucous
membranes and this hla-b 1502 allele is
positively correlated to carbamazepine
associated SGS te n there is a very
strong ethnic association mainly with
individuals of Southeast Asian descent
including those from Taiwan Hong Kong
Singapore Thailand Malaysia and India
and you can see that the allele
frequency is much higher in Southeast
Asians as compared to for example
Caucasians the second piper sensitivity
drug hypersensitivity pharmacogenetic
application I'm going to going to talk
about is hla-b 5701
as it relates to the drug a back of year
abacavir is a nucleoside analogue
commonly used in AIDS patients and it
inhibits hiv-1 reverse transcriptase now
approximately five to eight percent of
AIDS patients develop a hypersensitivity
reaction to a vaca beer which is very
nonspecific can sometimes appear as the
flu symptoms include fever rash headache
GI symptoms and this typically develops
within six weeks of initiation there's a
very strong association between HOH lav
5701 and a back of your hypersensitivity
in caucasians and you can see here in
this 2004 publication if there was an
odds ratio of 960 for this association
another study published in 2008 of the
loop New England Journal showed that
hla-b 5701 screening can be used for
risk stratification of patients with a
positive predictive value of about fifty
eight percent and a negative predictive
value of about a one hundred percent so
both hla-b 1502 and 5701 can be useful
tests in the clinical setting for drug
hypersensitivity okay now I'm going to
move on and talk a little bit about own
pharmacogenetic applications in
psychiatry so mostly psychotropic
medications are metabolized by
cytochrome p450 enzymes these
psychotropic medications include
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
or SSRIs tricyclic antidepressants or
TCAs sound benzodiazepines and
antipsychotics and the major sips
involved in metabolism are sip 26 1 a 2
3 a 4 to see nine and to see 19 and so
you can see here this is just a short
list of some of the psycho therapeutics
metabolized by 2c9 to see 19
226 so first I'm going to touch on sip
26 which is really a very interesting
gene and it's also a very important gene
and enzyme because it's involved
primarily or substantially in the
metabolism of 25% of drugs it's
important for the metabolism of TCAs
SSRIs and antipsychotics and it's a very
highly polymorphic gene so there's
greater than 160 genetic alterations
known in this gene so it's very very
polymorphic and again what I showed from
what I showed him one of the earlier
sides we break down the genotype of 69
sorry sub 26 and translated into a
phenotype which would be poor
intermediate extensive ultra-rapid
metabolizer and here is the phenotype
prevalence so in Caucasians they can
have a five to ten percent frequency of
poor metabolizer status and a seven
percent frequency of ultra-rapid
metabolizer status african-americans and
asians really have not demonstrated a
significant frequency of ultra-rapid
metabolizers but they do about one to
three percent of them are poor
metabolizers and their current
guidelines which is not in any of the
drug labels but these are kind of the
general guidelines out there is that if
an individual is a poor metabolizer the
dose of their drug should be reduced
about six to ten fold or they should be
given an alternative drug that's not
metabolized by sub 26 intermediate
metabolizers should be started at the
lowest efficacious dose and ultra-rapid
metabolizers should be given a two to
five fold increase in ghosts depending
on the number of duplications so the 686
gene can be have multiple copies
multiple full copies of the gene which
are all active
and so depending on the number of full
copies that are present one we want to
increase the dosage accordingly or they
could be given a drug 'let's not
metabolized by said 26 well they could
be given additional drugs or drug that
are metabolized by 686 to sort of bring
down the amount that the drug of
interest is metabolized just sort of
balance that out okay as I mentioned 626
is a very interesting gene and it can
have full gene duplications of multiple
copies you can also have full genome
deletions and clinically we can detect
these deletions and duplications and
these deletions and duplications occur
because there is a set of pseudogenes
upstream in the sub 26 gene that can
cause a non homologous recombination
another interesting thing that can occur
is that because sip 27 and 686 are so
close are so similar genetically
crossing over can occur within the genes
and can lead to these sip 2776 hybrids
and those are more challenging and those
are non-functional and but they're more
challenging for us to accurately detect
in a clinical lab so we need to be
careful about our approach to sip 286
genetic testing okay um I did talk about
69 earlier in regards to warfarin
however I just wanted to highlight that
it's also involved in the metabolism of
some antidepressants and anti-lock disc
and with work right I just touched on
the star two and star three alleles
there are other alleles that can affect
the activity of 69 such as star four
five and six they're much rarer but
nonetheless we can detect those and we
do in our clinical assays and sip to see
19 I also talked about
but in relationship integral and this is
also an important enzyme for
metabolizing some psychotropic
medications and I only talked about star
2 star 3 and star 17 in relation to
clopidogrel but there are at least 25
polymorphic variants in this gene
including star 45 and star eight okay
and then at as far as pharmacogenetic
applications for psychotherapy psycho
therapeutic drugs the serotonin
receptors are also an important on
clinical tests so HT r2a and to see are
the serotonin receptors that are
generally tested for and their
associated with response to ssris and
some atypical antipsychotics and a
typical just means that they're the
first generation antipsychotics and
interestingly they're also associated
with with weight gain associated with
some antipsychotics and increased risk
of tardive dyskinesia and then i believe
this is the final gene i'm talking about
in relation to psychotherapeutic
medications and this is the serotonin
transporter gene known as slc 6 a-4
there's a common linked polymorphic
region HTT lpr which is located in a
promoter and this is a 44 base pair
promoter insertion and deletion that
produces the long and short alleles now
the short allele is dominant so if an
individual has one or two copies of the
short allele that is the phenotype that
is going to be produced so they'll have
a decreased concentration of the
transporter protein a poor response to
stressful events and a up to 12 week
response time
SSRI therapy on those individuals who
have the law no Leo that they actually
need two copies of long we are a little
bit luckier and that they will have a
shorter response to SSRI therapy and of
course the long real phenotype is is
rarer there's also a variant in the long
allele which is an a to a G variant and
individuals who have two copies of the
long a a real have fewer adverse events
associated with SSRIs I should point out
that these these are the common variants
tested for in slc 684 but there are
other variants that can be looked at as
well ok and I'm going to move on to a
different clinical drug application in
pharmacogenetics and this has to do with
the thiopurines 6 style guanine and
6-mercaptopurine as well as is a
thiophene which is actually rapidly
converted to six McCaffrey puny so 60 g
and six MP are chemotherapeutic ages
used in the treatment of acute
lymphoblastic leukemia a ll is a thigh
cream isn't a notice of present given to
patients with auto employment or e bowel
disease and following kidney and heart
transplant thiopurines are all given as
prodrugs again where they have to be
converted to their active form once in
the body and so they do undergo a quite
extensive metabolism to produce their
active forms which are that cytotoxic
fire wanting nucleotides or tgms and
they've become inserted into the DNA and
RNA thiopurine methyltransferase is the
predominant in activation pathway in
hematopoietic cells so it's the
predominant pathway that inactivates the
thigh of hearings and you can see here
in this slide it's a little bit
complicated so I'm going to great detail
but you have 6 MP and yellow 6mo kept
appearing and 60 G green and you can see
the different pathways that undergoes to
become active file on e inform the T
James and then in opals with the red
shading you see TPMT which is converting
these drugs to inactive forms to be
eliminated from the body excuse me so
obviously somebody who has decreased
TPMT activity is going to have increased
levels of these drugs that could produce
toxic side effects so the clearance
again of these drugs is dependent on TPT
PMT activity and back in nineteen eighty
doctor Winchell dome here at the Mayo
Clinic actually discovered that TPMT
activity has a try mobile distribution
with most 89 most people 89% having a
high activity about ten to eleven
percent having an intermedium activity
and a point three percent having a low
or under to undetectable activity and so
this could really be classified as
extensive intermediate and poor new tab
Wiser's TPMT deficiency can lead to
severe and potentially life-threatening
myelosuppression or gametic toxicity in
patients taking thiopurines and it's
very serious situation so in 2003 the
fda updated the six MP and is a
therapeutic package inserts to indicate
that genotyping or phenotyping which is
an enzyme based assay can be performed
to assess TPMT deficiency status there's
really a three major star alleles NT PMT
that are tested for in the genetic test
these include star 2 star 3 a and star 3
C and you can show this here you can see
on this slide here the different
variants
that are detected with these star
alleles and my testing for these three
star wheels this accounts for greater
than ninety percent of cases with low or
intermediate TPMT activity and now as I
mentioned there is a phenotype now say
and it's an enzyme activity test that
can we used as an alternative to
genotyping and this test is based on the
rate of formation of six methyl
mercaptan peering in erythrocytes or red
blood cells so red blood cell TPMT
activity has been shown to be inversely
related to red blood cell file guanine
concentration enchanting with leukemia
which is what we would expect and then
this TPMT a different enzyme deficiency
is performed by this test is associated
with again the severe myelosuppression
and on Panetta buddhic toxicity okay I
believe this is the last drug
pharmacogenetic application that I'm
going to be talking about today and this
is for 5-fluorouracil also known as 5-fu
and this is a chemotherapeutic drug used
to treat solid tumors it can be given in
single or combination therapy adverse
side effects can occur with this drug
including myelosuppression
cardiotoxicity mucositis hand-foot
syndrome and diarrhea and a really high
percentage of patients greater than
thirty percent treated with 5-fu
experience severe drug related toxicity
so five of you has a complicated
metabolic pathway so there's a few
different genes involved in the
pharmacogenetic application of 5-fu the
first of these is the d PYD june which
is in code which encodes for dihedral
pyrimidine dehydrogenase or dpd this
enzyme is involved in the catabolism of
pyrimidines and it plays a key metabolic
role for five of you
metabolising greater than eighty percent
of the drug and DP d deficiency is
linked to severe 5-fu toxicity about
three to five percent of the population
is heterozygous for a deficiency allele
and d PYD and there's also complete deep
DP d deficiency complete DP d deficiency
that has been reported it's rare but it
has been reported in pediatric patients
with high levels of thymine and uracil
and in my body fluids it's also
associated with neurologic abnormalities
so it's a very severe condition the DP
YJ has is pretty polymorphic with over
30 single nucleotide polymorphisms and
deletion mutations at least 17 of them
associated with severe by the few
toxicity one of the common d PYD
variance is the star to a allele which
is a splicing variant in intron 14 and
its present in about forty to fifty
percent of patients with partial or
complete DP d deficiency additionally um
a very promoter methylation can occur
with DP why do we need to partial DP d
deficiency another gene involved in fife
fe disposition is tyms thymidylate
synthase and this is a target enzyme of
5-fu so this is one of those
pharmacodynamic applications survive a
few binds to the middle weight since
synthase with folate as a cofactor and
there's a common vntr in the five prime
untranslated region which is a 28 base
pair repeat and there can be from four
to nine repeats oh actually I'm sorry
the range is broader than that but the
most common is 2 to 3 10 and repeats of
this bntr there are rarer alleles on
four and nine repeats but the three copy
repeat
reduces greater tyms expression and a
poor response to five of you so it was
shown that stage three colorectal cancer
patients who are homozygous for the
three cappy repeat may not benefit from
5-fu and three copy repeat as president
a high frequency and caucasians and
asians there's also a six base pair
deletion in a 3 prime utr that's in
strong linkage disequilibrium with the
five prime tandem repeat and then
finally methylenetetrahydrofolate
reductase or MTHFR and 5-fu
pharmacogenetics is is potentially a
questionable of questionable relevance
to five a few pharmacogenetics some
studies have shown a strong association
but there is controversy in the
literature so MTHFR metabolizes the
folate cofactor needed for thymidylate
synthase inhibition by five of you an
impairment of this enzyme increases the
rate of activity of TS and there's a
common polymorphism that 677 c2 team
we're in heterozygous will have sixty
percent enzyme activity and homozygous
will have thirty percent enzyme activity
and the tmobile is associated with 5-fu
toxicity again there's some controversy
in the literature and there's also other
probably worse probably other
polymorphisms in this gene that may also
be associated with 5-fu toxicity okay so
this essentially ends my slide set so
just to summarize pharmacol genetic
tests can help to determine the
appropriate drug in some cases the
appropriate dose the goals of
pharmacogenetic testing our to maximize
efficacy and minimize side effects and
there are many different pharmacogenetic
tests available for a variety of
different applications including
cardiology and hematology as we showed
with soap to see knives of to see 19
there's also
pharmacogenetic tests related to Staten
myopathies which I didn't talk about but
that's the SL Co 1v1 gene there's many
different pharmacol unit tests related
to psychiatry which I talked about and I
didn't touch on sip funny too but that's
another one that can fall under the
psychiatry realm different tests
available available oncology
gastroenterology neurology and
infectious disease so it's a very
promising area that's growing quite a
bit and so again this concludes my slide
set but I do see that there are some
questions that some individuals have
posed so I will actually go to these
questions and I will read them out loud
here okay so I one question here from
Paul from body harmonics and his
question is with warfarin how accurate
have you found me a real associated
dosing to be this is a great question
and we have actually found a very good
association with the chart that's in the
package insert and and the dose that
patients actually receive that's
correlated to their genotype there are
some cases where certain other factors
need to be taken into consideration for
example if the patient is very large or
if they're elderly and have other
comorbidities so there are certain tools
actually online tools that can help to
make those adjustments that take into
account genotype comorbidities patient
wait and things like that but overall we
found that the chart provided in the
drug label is quite accurate so thank
you for that question
okay so another question I'm just
reading here is from Daniel from Kobol
products incorporated and his question
is do you see the pharmacogenetic
testing to determine a patient's
metabolic reaction to a drug becoming
more prevalent in the future or do you
think that it won't catch on because the
approximate thirty percent improvement
in a patient is not enough to cause real
change in a clinical setting if I
understand this question correctly
Daniels asking if the thirty percent
approximately thirty percent improvement
is significant enough to entice
clinicians to want to order this testing
and my opinion is that I think it is
some studies for example the Mayo the
medical Mayo study have shown that this
thirty percent improvement as a
significant financial impact in terms of
especially when we consider
hospitalization and all the costs
associated with hospitalization if you
look at something like clopidogrel and
if the patient's taking it and they have
a stint in and a stent ree thrombosis
this can lead to you know significant
medical interaction which is very costly
and it may only be thirty percent the
population but it's important enough
that I believe pharmacogenetic testing
is really going to catch on and I think
part of the reason why pharmacogenetic
testing has only caught on with certain
groups is because there's still a lot of
questions out there and a lot of
education that needs to take place I
believe that some clinicians probably
don't know what to do with pharmacol
genetic information that they receive
and so there's again there's some
education that means
place but I think I think the more
studies that come out my outcome studies
that come out will help to support this
type of testing thank you for that
question I hope I answered it okay okay
another question is from Francisco from
usf cube and this question is are these
pharmacogenetic applications how can
overcome okay sorry this must be a okay
it's a question about epigenetics and
how do we deal with the epigenetics
factor and I think this is a great
question right now in a research setting
we can definitely take a look at the
epigenetics in the clinical setting
we're getting there and it there are
some cases for example mlh1 promoter
methylation is looked at and that's
really shown a significant association
with a response to I'm blanking but it
for colon cancer however I think at this
point there aren't there's enough strong
evidence to support much at the genetic
testing for other pharmacogenetic
applications so i think that's going to
be an up-and-coming area but it's
something that's definitely doable that
we can test for in the clinical setting
I hope I answered that question
correctly to I'm not sure I quite
understood it but thank you for your
question okay another question oh this
is a good question now this is from in
do this is what is the scenario of
pharmacogenetics and complex disorders
as coronary artery disease so as far as
as far as CEO d no I think I think that
maybe there's two parts this question
one is looking for genetic associations
in coronary
disease and the other question is
pharmacogenetics and drug really drug
therapies based on genetic testing now
if we're looking for genetic
associations of coronary artery disease
you're probably aware that there have
done some associations found for example
the 19 21 region however is you know as
you even as you pointed out in your
question it is see ad is very complex
and it's really hard for us to strongly
pinpoint genetic associations with ced
and some companies are thinking about a
highly multiplex approach looking at you
know 50 different variants that may be
associated with CAT to help predict
whether or not somebody is going to have
a cardiovascular event I was far as
pharmacogenetics this is also one of
those areas that is sort of a work in
progress there are some pharmacogenetic
applications for example as I mentioned
statins and Stanton myopathy with the
slc 01 be one gene article just came out
in circulation cardiovascular genetics I
think it came out last week which I
encourage you to take a look at and that
showed that there was a significant
association of statin myopathy and slc
01 b 1 and a june called abcg2 um
there's also with coronary artery
disease you know we have the clitoral
story but other than that there aren't
really many other pharmacogenetic
applications for coronary artery disease
thank you for your question
okay another question is from Louisville
from Arab International University what
are the lives of pharmacogenetics well
this is a great question too so there
are several limits including the gene
tested for Mina the testing of the gene
may not be comprehensive enough so nor
may not be finding everything in the
gene that affects its function so we may
be missing pieces and you know this can
be related to the question before about
epigenetics we're not potentially
looking at the epigenetic modifications
of the gene they may not be looking for
certain intronic variants that we don't
know about that affect function of the
protein so not only limitations of the
gene were testing but limitations to the
genes were testing a lot of these drugs
have highly complex metabolism and
activation pathways so for example 5-fu
is very complex and I just talked about
three genes one of them that has a
questionable pharmacogenetic relevance
and you know there's other enzymes
involved in 5-fu disposition and so you
know it's hard for us to really wrap our
heads around the entire picture of how
much testing we should do for how many
genes we should test and how many
regions of the genes we should test so
I'd say there's those limitations
there's also limitations to cost so you
know the more things we look for the
more expensive the test becomes and the
less likely it's going to be ordered
also the more things we look for the
more complicated the interpretation
becomes so you know for example if you
look at siff to see 19 what if you have
a patient who is star 2 and then star 17
* 17 is that promote a very that
activates the enzyme start to basically
it inhibits the enzyme activity so if
you have those in combination are they
going to cancel each other out
we have normal enzyme activity nobody
really knows so that's another
limitation is that when we see a
combination of the meals sometimes we're
not quite sure of how to interpret those
results and I could go on with other
examples on like soap 2d6 and which is a
complicated gene in itself so those are
some of the major limitations that I can
think of at this point okay another
question from bandana the question is
does pharmacogenomics play a major role
in heritable disease so there are some
some of these genes as I mentioned with
you for example as I mentioned with
ugt1a1 ugt1a1 can have variants in it
that cause hereditary disorders of
bilirubin metabolism and these disorders
are visual bear syndrome which is
essentially a benign condition of
elevated unconjugated bilirubin but if
an individual has more severe mutations
in this gene it can cause crigler najar
types 1 and 2 which are much more severe
hyper bilirubin disorders I'm ugt1a1
again is also involved in a reno tkm
metabolism so sometimes patients who
have high bilirubin and they may be a
candidate for you know T can their high
bilirubin is a clue to their provider
that they may not be a good candidate
for immuno to you can and I can't think
at this off the top of my head I can't
think of any other genes involved in
pharmacogenetics that are also involved
in hereditary disorders um except i just
remembered one the gene that's involved
in anthony Bixler syndrome which i'm
blanking on the name of that gene has a
pharmacogenetic application
and I'm blanking on the pharmacogenetic
application I think the gene is called
poor yes so that that's another
application thank you for your question
okay a question from emilio from italy
the university of genoa most of the
examples recorded pertain to clinical
validity on the opposite rarely we have
evidence on clinical utility for example
the case of a back of your mixing up the
presence of association of clinical
utility can be misleading and might
explain why guidelines are sometimes non
Concordat for example warfarin would you
comment on this I agree and I think that
this is this is one of the major
limitations to uptake a pharmacogenetic
testing so we can find these great
associations and we can find them
retrospectively but what the clinicians
are really looking for is strong
prospective clinical prospective
randomized clinical outcomes evidence
that will help support their decision to
order this type of testing or not now
the problem with these types of studies
of them is that they in order to reach
statistical significance they have to be
very large and they have and they're
very expensive so this is why a lot of
these studies are not done even though
these types of studies would probably
learn to the most support for actual
clinical utility so that was a great
question thank you Emilio
and then a comment basically from Indian
again the association of slc 0 1 v1 and
abcg2 with myopathy has not been
reproduced in all populations thank you
for that comment yes that is a very good
point it has not been reproduced in all
populations and this is actually a
similar story for any of these
pharmacogenetic applications is that
they're not necessarily applicable to
all populations and with this myopathy
education it's not application it's not
applicable to all statins as well so the
main drug involved with slc OMB one is
simvastatin and with abcg2 is at the
minutes a tourist and thank you for that
comment and the final question that i
have here is from ekaterina on do you
want a pharmacogenetic testing for heart
failure complications of anti-cancer
therapy that's a good question and I do
not know of any pharmacogenetic tests
and as far as I'm aware you know I've
heard of this topic before I'm not that
familiar with it but I believe it are
some studies going on looking at this
but i do not know of anything that's
clinically available at this time so
that is the end of my questions and also
it's been an hour so let me go to the
the cme's 5 and i wanted to just thank
you all for attending this presentation
and for your great questions to obtain
continuing education credits please go
to this website that's listed here thank
you very much for your time
you